bonjour François baayrou bonjour vous
êtes le président du MoDem haut
commissaire au Plan et maire de pot ce
soir demain et après-demain nous réserve
des moments très politiques la loi
immigration sera-t-elle adoptée c'est la
question ça dépend des républicains puis
de la majorité et donc aussi des députés
modemes de vos troupes François baayrou
et au-delà de cette douloureuse ou
compliquée loi immigration comment
Emmanuel Macron peut-il encore relancer
son quinquena grand discours changement
de Premier ministre de gouvernement dis
solutions vous nous donnerez vos
solutions bienvenue dans ce grand jury
François baayrou à mécôé pour vous
interroger Pauline buisson de la
rédaction de M6 et Loris Boichot du
Figaro bonjour le moment je le disais
donc très politique le sort de la loi
immigration se joue dans les heures qui
viennent réunion ce soir à Matignon avec
la droite puis réunion de la dernière
chance entre SEP sénateurs et SEP
députés demain à l'Assemblée première
question ce grand jury posé par laoris
boachot François baayerou pour sortir de
l'enlisement votre camp va devoir se
mettre d'accord avec la droite Emmanuel
Macron a appelé un compromis intelligent
à quoi pourrait ressembler ce compromis
intelligent
euh d'abord faut noter que ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale qui est
absolument sans précédent sans exemple
c'est que sur un texte essentiel
l'Assemblée nationale a refusé
l'alliance des oppositions lundi avec
l'adoption d'une motion de rejet
préalable donc rejet du texte avant même
le début des débats et donc ça signifie
que les députés ont majoritairement
choisi dans une ambiance
d'applaudissement
d'exultation extrêmement choquante en
fait si vous y
réfléchissez ils ont choisi que
euh eux qui étaient élus pour voter la
loi en réalité refuseraient cette
mission
et je n'ai pas
souvenir que sur un texte de cette
importance
jamais l'Assemblée nationale est à ce
point écarté parce que vous êtes en
majorité relative et parce que gauche et
droite s'oppos à ce texte pour des
raisons différentes euh c'est exactement
ça ils ont voté ensemble majoritairement
quoique voulant le contraire les uns des
autres les uns veulent plus de plus
d'immigration les autres veulent
plus du tout d'immigration mais ils ont
décidé ensemble que leur mission de
députés pourquoi ils ont été élus c'est
ils se sont présentés devant les
électeurs pour remplir cette mission ils
ont ensemble décidé que ils écarterai le
devoir qui est le l'heure d'examiner la
loi cynisme des oppositions vous
reprendriez ces termees d'Emmanuel
Macron pardon le cynisme des oppositions
vous reprendriezes mot ou je j'essaie de
dépouiller le discours de de de des des
mises en cause les plus virulentes
j'essaie de voir ce qui se passe on en
est arrivé au point où après des mois et
des mois d'invectiv d'aboiement de de
d'insultes
perpétuel ils ont préféré ne pas
examiner le texte alors que ils étaient
élus pour ça et que chacun d'entre eux
pour des raisons différentes et même
diamétralement contrairees chacun
d'entre eux disait que ce texte était
tout à fait important pour les uns grave
pour les autres et donc je je pense
qu'il y a là une marche de plus
descendue dans euh au fond le le le
renimement euh des de la démocratie
représentative et ce reniment devra
finir parce que le pluralisme il est
parti pour longtemps et je de mon point
de vue heureusement que j'espère que
pendant longtemps on continuera à avoir
des élus qui feront leur travail et ces
élus un jour ou l'autre ils vont devoir
se rendre compte que les
institutions elles peuvent fonctionner
même dans circonstance plus incommode
qui est celle d'absence de majorité
alors maintenant sur le texte voilà vous
ne donnez pas d'indication pour la suite
là vous faites le constat de ce qui
s'est passé cette semaine je fais le
constat
navré plus que ça inquiet
parce que je suis persuadé que tous ceux
qui ont voté ne mesuraient pas les
conséquences de leur choix ce que ça
signifiait pour le le l'idée même qu'il
se faisait pour du débat on l'a bien
compris alors maintenant le texte il y a
une
question
première est-ce que il serait bon pour
la démocratie française qu'on ne trouver
qu'on ne trouve pas de de texte qu'on
puisse pas dégager un texte entre euh le
Sénat qui a voté euh ce texte qui va
être examiné et l'Assemblée nationale
puisque SEP représentants de l'Assemblée
des groupes de l'Assemblée euh vont euh
examiner le texte ensputé se sénateurs
SEP député cette sénateur et pour ma
part j'espère euh qu'ils vont trouver un
un accord alors cet accord euh à mon
sens il doit être examiné à la lumière
de ce que je crois très majoritairement
les Français veulent les Français
veulent qu'il y ait de la rigueur et si
possible je vais employer le mot de
souveraineté que que nous puissions
comme un état comme une
nation
réguler
les les entrées et les séjours sur notre
sol ils veulent qu'il y ait au fond de
l'efficacité de l'action publique public
quand il s'agit de contrôler et de
réguler quand quelqu'un fait des bêtises
qu'on puisse le ramener s'il est
illégal réellement qu'on puisse le
ramener et je crois que les Français
veulent en tout cas je m'exprime à titre
personnel je crois aussi que les
Français veulent que lorsque quelqu'un
est sur notre sol depuis
longtemps qu'il travaille qui fait
l'effort d'apprendre notre
langue c'est-à-dire qu'il considère que
le pays dans lequel il est c'est aussi
un pays dans
lequel on peut s'intégrer en ayant des
principes en
comprenant vous voulez voulez de la
fermeté manè de VI et la possibilité de
régulariser dans les métiers soutension
non oui les métiers soutension c'est une
expression que je n'aime pas parce que
quand quand vous vous trouver est-ce que
l'agriculture est un métier sousension
la réponse oui je crois dans la réponse
oui
et des artisans aussi on peut
trouver on peut
trouver travail je voudrais m'arrêter
une seconde à ce point on peut trouver
par le travail une possibilité de d'être
accepté dans un pays comme le nôtre
alors c'est pas à la mode aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas l'objet du texte mais comme
citoyen je pense que le jour viendra
vous dit vous dit vous dites c'est pas
l'objet du texte c'est dans le texte
adopté par le Sénat ce volet
régularisation est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
dans ce qu'il y a dans le texte qui est
finalement la base de discussion pour
les rendez-vous à venir que ce soit ce
soir demain ou même mardi avec un vote
possible de de l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que ce qu'il y a dans le texte du
Sénat vous convient ou pas ou est-ce que
il est dur des chos il y a des choses
qui me conviennent et que je trouve tout
à fait acceptable j'en donne une est-ce
que que quel un jeune garçon une jeune
fille qui est d'origine
étrangère et qui peut devenir français
en fonction de nos règles est-ce que il
est légitime de lui demander entre 16 et
18 ans si c'est bien sa volonté qu'on
devienne pas français par
mécanique et qu'on devienne français par
choix bon moi ça ne me gêne pas je
trouve ça tout à fait acceptable texte
du Sénat encore est-ce que quelqu'un qui
commet un
crime et qui est qui a une double
nationalité est-ce qu'on peut lui
enlever sa nationalité la part de sa
nationalité française alors qu'il a
commis un crime un crime c'est-à-dire
les actes les plus graves et notamment à
l'égard par exemple des forces de
l'ordre moi en tout cas ça ne me gêne
pas Lig roues alors dans le dans le
texte du Sénat je n'emploie jamais
l'expression de ligne rouge bon par que
l'expression de ligne rouge ça veut dire
je viens et mon état d'esprit c'est l'é
preuve de force je vais vous imposer ce
que je pense euh et donc pour poser la
question a il y a bien des choses qui
seront acceptables ou pas par le modem à
un moment il faudra s'ex d'abord le
modem les députés du MoDem sont très
jaloux de leur indépendance et ils ne
prennent pas des ordres même auprès de
leur président que je crois ils aiment
bien mais mais ils prennent pas
d'ordre alors les ce qui pour moi est
euh pas acceptable ça serait que euh
l'aide
médicale se trouve remise en question
parce que j'ai toujours trouvé cette
idée extrêmement dangereuse
euh lorsque vous avez quelqu'un qui
mettons qui est tuberculeux euh un un
jeune homme qui est tuberculeux qui a
passé les frontières et qui dans les
épreuves de tout ça attraper cette
maladie si grave vous ne le soignez pas
vous vous le
laissez dans la nature en train de
répandre hélas une maladie très grave à
ce stade des négociations ce volet là
serait sorti du texte et renvoyé à un
texte ultérieur pour le début d'année
vous dites à ce stade des négociations
vous en savez plus que moi donc je ne
dis pas ça moi je dis ce point-là l'aide
médicale le fait que on doit non
seulement pour des raisons humanitaires
mais pour des raisons de sécurité de
notre peuple on doit apporter les soins
à qui en a besoin pas des soins
exorbitants pas des soins esthétique
comme on l'a dit souvent c'est pas du
tout ça le sujet le sujet c'est lorsque
vous êtes frappé par une maladie grave
et bien on vous doit aide et assistance
et lorsque cette maladie grave de
surcroix va menacer la communauté à
laquelle vous appartenez on vous doit
aide et assistance j'ai un point euh que
que je n'aime pas dans le texte du
Sénat et qui a qui n'a pas souvent été
mise en valeur il y a dans le texte du
Sénat l'idée que pour des étudiants
étrangers qui viendrai étudier en France
on leur imposerait de payer une caution
pour être assuré que ils
repartiront moi je trouve que c'est pas
bien je trouve
que
discriminer les étudiants dont je dis
comme citoyen français que nous avons le
plus grand besoin c'est le rayonnement
de la France qui est en cause on a
besoin
euh comme un grand pays que nous
sommes je pense souvent à saingor par
exemple un archétype de de de d'un jeune
homme qui vient d'Afrique de très loin
de notre société et ce jeune homme-l qui
est le fruit d'un
commerçant ce sénégalais ce jeune
homme-là il va être une des plus grandes
figures de la France alors l'un des
points de prpation les plus fort j'ai
pas j'ai pas fini j'ai pas fini et donc
l'idée qu'en réalité on imposerait une
discrimination fondée sur quoi fondée
sur le fait de savoir si vous avez de
l'argent ou pas si votre famille a de
l'argent ou pas et bien ceci ceci ce
n'est pas la France la France c'est la
volonté de rayonner au travers de de de
son système universitaire en en en en
accueillant et en aidant à former des
jeunes gens qui après retournent dans
leur pays et qui participeront euh au
rayonnement de la France l'un des points
de crispation les plus forts et
notamment du côté de la droite c'est la
régularisation de travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension le
Sénat et la droite sénatoriale veut
restreindre ce dispositif là est-ce que
vous êtes prêt à faire cette concession
parce va bien savoir se mettre d'accord
on a parlé juste avant votre question
alors je je répète ce que je pense
version reste
moi moi comme citoyen je pense que
lorsque quelqu'un euh a euh traverser
euh toutes les épreuves que suppose le
fait d'entrer dans un métier euh et ce
métier de de le valoriser et de se
valoriser au travers du métier euh s'il
a conscience que il doit parler français
s'il a conscience que la France ça n'est
pas une page blanche euh
on n fait pas ce qu'on veut la France
c'est un pays qui a des coutumes des
manières de vivre des principes
philosophiques la laïcité en est un
laïcité c'est très simple en France ça
n'est pas c'est un croyant qui le dit ça
n'est pas la religion qui fait la
loi la loi protège les religions mais la
religion ne fait pas la loi donc il faut
mettre des critères strict selon vous
oui je pense que c'est pas le plus
difficile
le plus difficile pour un nombre de ceux
qui sont autour de la table et vous
voyez bien que moi je ne parle pas de de
bras de fer et des preuves de force le
plus difficile pour certaines
sensibilités
c'est d'accepter l'idée
que on on peut ne pas laisser les gens
dans la
clandestinité parce que pardon de dire
ça c'est un leure l'idée que on va
identifier et renvoyer chez eux
immédiatement encore faut-il que les
pays d'origine l'acceptent qui a trouvé
jusqu'à maintenant la réponse à
cela c'est c'est très très peu
le le ministre de l'Intérieur qui fait
l'effort de communiquer sur ce sujet il
publie tous les jours le fait qu'il y a
5 6 10 personnes qui sont raccompagnées
aux frontières si je sais bien faire la
multiplication 10 par jour ça fait 3000
par an c'est-à-dire on est évidemment
très loin des chiffres qui sont avancés
et donc je pense que ce sur quoi nous
devons être intransigeent c'est l'idée
que la France ne
se sa pas quoi
ne n'est pas un pays dans
lequel les principes de vie les coutumes
la manière d'être serait distribué au
hasard nous
avons une identité je arrête à cette
idée je pense que un très grand nombre
des questions et des angoisses qui se
posent à nos concitoyens sur ces sujets
c'est l'idée que notre identité serait
peu à peu remise en question c'est pas
le le
l'immigration marginale dans n vous êtes
sensible à cette angoisse vous la
comprenez et vous y êtes sensible je la
comprends et je pense même que ce droit
à l'identité d'une nation comme la nôtre
nous devrions la sacraliser je pense que
on pourrait la mettre dans la
Constitution chercher quelque chose
chercher une une formulation j'ai
proposé ça depuis longtemps vous qui
suivez mes œuvres complètes j'ai proposé
ça depuis longtemps que que qu'on puisse
dans notre
Constitution consacrer le droit
collectif de la communauté nationale que
nous formons à affirmé que son identité
n'est pas à
l'encant ça n'est pas distribuer au
petit bonheur la chance c'est pas parce
que vous avez telle conviction que vous
pouvez remettre en question notre
manière de vivre ensemble et je pense
que ça aiderait beaucoup
à à rassurer ceux qui sont inquiets sur
le devenir de la un autre point de
crispation et que vous n'avez pas évoqué
jusque là c'est le délis de séjours
irrégulier est-ce que pour vous c'est
quelque chose d'important ou de non
acceptable moi je pense que c'est
discutable le alors dél de séjour
euh ce qui est évoqué dans le texte est
une amende pour ses jours irréguliers
bon discutons-en c'est pas ça n'est pas
pour moi un point BL c'est pas un point
de blocage c'est pas quelque chose qui
pourrait pour moi non mais je encore une
fois je m'exprime à titre personnel et
et oui parce qu'on a l'impression que
vous êtes plus ferme que vos troupes de
députés qui sont pour des
régularisations plus importantes une
version
de disposi par rapport à la droite
est-ce que il y a pas le risque de
rendre illisible la position du MoDem
entre vous-même et vos troupe qui
parfois font figure d gauche de la
majorité sur ces sujetsl je suis
monsieur boot très très partisant de
vous reconnaître un droit d'expertise
sur notre courant
politique mais c'est absolument pas vrai
ce que vous dites est pas vrai jamais le
groupe a dit qu'il voulait plus euh de
d'être euh excessif sur ce point je
répète ce que je pense le groupe ces
derniers jours a fait valoir sa
vigilance sur des régular un dispositif
sur les régularisations pour les
travailleurs dans les métiers enention
plus important un dispositif plus
important que celui de la droite par
Bach je comprends que vous veniez avec
des questions euh mais excusez-moi de
vous dire j'ai plaidé dès le début que
pour moi l'attitude alors je parle même
pas du texte l'attitude euh que nous
devons avoir en face de ces questions
c'est d'un côté une rigueur une
accélération des procédures le fait que
nous puissions être assurés que l'action
publique sera efficace dans la maîtrise
de ces questions et deuxièmement le fait
que oui il y a des gens qui qui peuvent
qui doivent s'intégrer parce qu'ils ont
choisi le travail je vous donne un
exemple simple et j'ajoute une idée
après l'exemple simple c'est j'ai eu
récemment m'occuper d'un d'un jeune
homme arrivé comme mineur
isolé venant d'un pays
d'Afrique qui a commencé un
apprentissage de boulanger de boulanger
pâtissier et il réussit très
bien il arrive à l'âge critique de 17 ou
18 ans et on lui met une qtf une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français est-ce que ça a du
sens et c'est son et c'est son patron
qui dit mais comprenez-moi bien je
trouve personne on trouve personne pour
faire not Conz des arguments contre ce
type de de situation c'est-à-dire que à
partir du moment où on régularise par
exemple le jeûne que vous évoquez
certains redoutent un appel d'air
c'est-à-dire que ça veut dire et le
message envoy parce vous trouvez qu'il
n'y a pas d'appel
d'air le le si on régularise ça veut
dire que on peut continuer de venir en
France pour être régularisé c'est nous
sommes fermes et est juste sur le fait
que le travail est une voie
d'intégration je j'ai j'ai fait un
exercice tout à fait intéressant j'ai
regardé ce immigrés ou issu de
l'immigration parce qu'on mélange
évidemment les deux il y a évidemment
des Français qui sont fils d'immigrer à
des
générations et qui sont pris dans des ou
même des crimes je regarde
ça proportion dans dans cela de ceux qui
travaille est
infime c'est des sans travail qui
commettent toutes ces exaction contre
lesquelles on est si profondément ému et
donc je pense que le travail est une
voie d'intégration mais je vous avis
promis une idée
euh en réalité la
vraie Réponse la vraie construction
législative euh la
vraie nécessité pour que l'action
publique soit
efficace et bien c'est que tous les pays
européens la fassent ensemble et on est
en train précisément il y a des députés
européens qui sont avec nous euh euh
onasile immigration qui est encore en
discussion à la TR précisément on est
sur le point d'adopter un texte qui est
extrêmement protecteur donc ce que vous
dites c'est que la loi immigration n'est
pas suffisante par moi je pense que sur
ce sujet nous connaîtrons des
générations et des génération de lois
toutes insuffisantes on essaie d'adapter
au fur et à mesure c'est pour ça que
c'est pas la peine de faire des
Himalayas avec chaque fois avec un texte
chaque fois qu'on le présente en réalité
c'est symbolique tout ça le le travail
européen que nous sommes en train de
faire et que précisément les députés
européens sont en train de faire qui est
euh d'efficacité à la frontière et
d'identification aux frontières de
l'Union euh et de d'identification de
ceux qui arrivent et qui passent
l'obligation de demander euh un visa une
autorisation de présence avant de
franchir la frontière tout ça c'est on
est en train ces jours-ci personne n'en
parle parce qu'on vit dans une espèce de
de de cloisonnement complètement stupide
on est en train précisément de mettre au
point ce texte et de l'adopter au
Parlement européen ben c'est 10 fois
plus efficace et pour qu'un grand nombre
des moulinets que nous faisons euh ou
des mots qui se prononcent avec la
bouche mais qui suivent pas qui ne qui
ne sont pas alors pour reprendén
justement pour reprendre le fil des
prochaines heures et de cette loi
immigration symbolique dites-vous est-ce
que vous préférierez un un échec des
négociations demain entre sénateur et
député plutôt qu'un texte soit trop dur
soit pas à votre convenance et donc
invotable le lendemain à l'Assemblée
nationale par je préfère la réussite je
pense que tous ceux qui spéculent sur
l'idée que il faut échouer et que
échouer ça fera plus ou davantage
progresser les choses j'en crois rien et
donc en cas d'accord demain est-ce que
vous pouvez nous assurer qu'il ne
manquera aucune voix dans la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale vous n'avez pas
compris peut-être Figaro peut-être
Figaro il y a quelqu'un qui donne des h
et tout le monde obéit c'est possible
que ce soit en ordre mais chez nous au
Mouvement Démocrate s'appelle comme ça
pas par hasard dans ce mouvement là qui
met la citoyenneté au premier plan et la
responsabilité au premier plan mais
liberté dans ce mouvement là les
parlementaires prennent leur sauf que
chaque vois compte vous le savez très
bien dans une situation de majorité
relative l ça pourrait être à l'origine
d'un échec lors d'un vote final à
l'Assemblée et bien je ne souhaite pas
l'échec mais est-ce que vous craignez un
éclatement de cette majorité
présidentielle relative je ne crois pas
j'entends beaucoup de spéculations sur
ce sujet j'entends beaucoup
naturellement d'expression d'état d'âme
dans les
couloirs ben c'est normal d'avoir des
états d'âes j'en ai moi-même comme vous
avez
entendu je pense
que l'équilibre du texte est à
préserver mais cependant je ne je ne
crois pas que s'il y a un accord en
commission mixte paritaire les
parlementaires vont prendre le risque
ils en ont déjà pris un gravissime de
renoncer à faire la loi hein vous savez
la définition de l'Assemblée
nationale dit c'est Corps législatif
est-ce qu'il a une remise en cause
nécessaire dans la méthode peut-être
après l'échec justement de est-ce qu'on
a vu les limites du en même temps
finalement lundi c'est-à-dire que pour
le coup on a eu du en même temps mais
c'est en même temps la gauche et en même
temps la droite qui a voté contre le
gouvernement ou j'entends j'entends cet
argument tourner en boucle sur un
certain nombre de plateaux ou la limite
du pardonnez-moi je le trouve stupide
pourquoi
je comment vous pouvez-vous faire une
loi sur l'immigration sans tenir compte
en même temps du sentiment populaire
profond des inquiétudes qui anime les
gens de la volonté de défendre une
identité toute chose que j'ai défendu
devant vous et
des drames humains la question M
politique Françis
Baou j'entends bien alors je défend la
politique je suis un homme du centre
toute ma vie politique elle est dans
cette idée
que la bipolarisation est un malheur
pour un pays si vous regardez les échecs
que nous avons connu au travers du temps
c'est parce qu'on est passé d'un bord
sur l'autre euh tous les 5 ans ou tous
les 8 ans si vous regardez la société
américaine le le drame euh c'est qu'on
se trouve dans une société euh euh avec
des divisions bipolaires exacerbées par
Trump d'un côté euh d'autres de l'autre
côté et qui en souffre c'est les
États-Unis qui en souffrent euh le
devoir d'un responsable politique c'est
de consacrer et cultiver l'unité du pays
et vous et vous ne trouve l'unité du
pays que dans cette position qu'on
appelle
centrale et qui a été définie une fois
pour toute par quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelait Marc sangier qui
a dit la démocratie c'est l'organisation
sociale qui porte à son plus haut la
conscience et la responsabilité du
citoyen François Baou conscience et la
responsabilité et ceci devrait nous
faire un programme écrit en lettrre d'or
que nous auquel tous les démocrates
devraient s'acharner à ne pas manquer
bon cette situation politique François
Baayou et la suite les conséquences
notamment avec une loi immigration
adoptée ou pas les conséquences sur la
suite du quinquen on en parle dans un
instant dans la seconde partie du Grand
Jury à tout de
suite suite du Grand Jury présenté par
Olivier Bost François Baou au
commissaire au Plan président du MoDem
et maire de poau et notre invité nous
allons essayer de nous projeter un petit
peu en cas d'échec au Parlement la
semaine prochaine avec la loi
immigration Emmanuel Macron a prévenu
qu'il retirerait son texte une question
de Pauline buisson oui François Baayou
qui serait selon vous le ou les perdant
si la loi n'était pas adoptée ellisabeth
borne Gérald armanin les républicains
est-ce le quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron
même tout entier qui moi je pense que
dépassant les considérations purement
politiciennes
à l'intérieur des murs du palais Bourbon
et ailleurs et au
Sénat dépassant cela les perdant serait
tous ceux qui pensent que c'est un sujet
important et sur lequel il faut prendre
des décisions des décisions pour
protéger disent les uns des décisions de
justice disent les autres cela serait
les perdants c'est-à-dire tout le monde
l'idée que il des gens qui pourraient se
frotter les mains parce qu'ils aur
empêcher notre
ensemble de gouvernement et de majorité
et d'assemblée et de Sénat d'adopter un
texte que tous prétendent crucial s'il y
avait des gens qui disaient franchement
on s'en fiche c'est on en a pas besoin
mais tout le monde sincèrement ou pas
disent qu'on en a besoin on serait donc
tous perdants en
cas les conséquen
en cas d'che je pense que le Président
de la République a raison il faut
retirer le texte et changer de
gouvernement également est-il faut aller
auelà ça c'est sa responsabilité et Dieu
sait qu'elle est pas simple à exercer
non je pense que il a
raison je me suis opposé depuis le début
à ce qu'il y ait un 493 sur ce
texte parce que j'ai proposé une grille
de lecture qui de dire il y a deux
sortes de lois il y a les lois vitales
le budget est une loi it on a des 49
fois sur le budget parce que si vous
n'avez pas de budget vous pouvez pas
gouverner c'est fini à l'instant même ça
s'arrête donc ça c'est une loi vitale et
le gouvernement dit si vous l'adoptez
pas c'est mon existence qui est en jeu
ça s'appelle le 493 et je dis au passage
je n'ai jamais rien compris aux gens qui
prétendent que le 493 ça ne serait pas
démocratique c'est la démocratie par
excellence c'est ce texte est nécessaire
à ma vie si vous refuser ce texte c'est
moi qui m'en vais donc pas de 493 sur
sur l'immigration mais en revanche il y
a des textes utiles j'ai dit des textes
vitaux et il y a des textes utiles on
voit bien que la situation sur
l'immigration aujourd'hui par exemple
prenant le sujet des procédures
interminables qui fait que quelqu'un
dans la procédure détournée de l'asile
parce que la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui l'asile est une procédure
complètement détournée c'est
le droit d'asile l'invocation du droit
d'asile c'est le moyen d'ouvrir une
porte sur un séjour plus ou moins long
dans la société française on demande à
bénéficier de l'asile même si on a aucun
droit venant de pays qui ne justifie pas
de l'asile et la multiplication des
procédures fait que 4 ou 5 ans après
vous êtes toujours là évidemment à ce
moment-là une situation de désordre très
profond et créé donc l'accélération des
procédures est une mesure bonne juste je
reviens je reviens à la situation la
situation politique et les conséquences
éventuel d'un échec sur la loi
immigration sur le plan politique ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que il
faudrait par exemple un Premier ministre
issu de la droite pour pouvoir continuer
à gouverner pour Emmanuel Macron alors
je je vous trouve formidable Divier Bost
et donc je vais essayer d'exprimer mon
admiration euh je depuis le premier jour
de mon engagement dans la vie politique
française vous ne voulez pas de la
droite pas de la gauche je refuse qu'on
résume le débat à droite contre
gauche je vais vous dire des choses il y
a des gens droit ex moment vous avez
quand même défendu ellisabeth borne vous
vouliez pas nécessairement de Catherine
Vautrin qui était plutôt issu de la
droite pour pour matigon ceci n'a rien à
voir mais on en parlera une autre fois
bon mais en cas d'échec comment faire
pour relancer le quinena on comprend
bien que il y a un point crucial oui euh
et donc
euh le gouvernement c'est la décision
personnelle du président de la
République euh et c'est sûr que c'est
mieux des gouvernements qui réussissent
à faire passer des textes que des
gouvernements qui échouent à faire
passer les textes j'enfonce des portes
ouverte parce que euh ça mérite
quelquefois qu'on rappelle des vous
renforcez pas Élisabeth borne si ça se
passe mal mardi s rappelle des évidences
ce euh ça n'est pas un jugement
personnel que je porte h euh je pense
pour dire le fond de ce que je crois je
pense qu'on n'a pas compris
encore ce que c'était que la 5e
République en l'absence de majorité la
5e République a été fondée précisément
par le général de Gaulle qui a
la magnifiquement superbement exprimé
dès 1946 dans un discours à Bailleux ce
qu'a dit le général de Gaulle c'est nous
allons enlever l'exécutif aux manœuvres
parlementaires c'est pas les ententes
entre partis qui font le gouvernement
c'est le président de la République qui
nommera le gouvernement écoutez bien à
partir de là j'ouvre la parenthèse
j'ouvre les guillemets je le cite en
tenant compte des nuances de l'Assemblée
nationale et est-ce que c'est ce qu'a
fait
Emmanuel du tout ça n'est pas du
tout l'esprit des coalitions à
l'allemande
les coalitions à l'allemande ça vient
des partis et la logique de la 5e
République ça vient de celui qui est élu
au suffrage universel par tous les
Français parce qu'il présente une vision
de l'avenir et qu'on a confiance dans sa
personalité ça veut dire forme la
majorité d'accord mais est-ce
queemmanuel Macron qui a fait des choix
après sa réélection en 2022 et après
avoir perdu en quelque sorte les les
élections législatives est-ce qu'il doit
revoir ce dispositif perdu les élections
il n pas gagné la majorité absolue il a
pas gagné m euh et moi je pense que
c'est la logique des temps dans lesquels
nous sommes
entrés regardez tous les problèmes
pensez à la table de famille h il y
avait une époque où tout le monde euh
pensait et votait la même chose c'était
le chef de famille dans les familles
pyrénéennes dont je suis grosso modo
tout le monde alors quelque fois la mère
de famille se cachait parce qu'elle
votait pas exactement comme le père de
famille des choses qui arrivaient mais
grosso modo quand on avait les élections
on comptait famille par famille mais
c'est complètement fini je je vous avez
aujourd'hui des sensibilités différentes
des songeer au aux explosions autour de
la table de famille sur la
vaccination songeer à tous les problèmes
qui se posent à partir de la
géopolitique mondiale les ou à propos de
l'environnement euh on est entré et je
m'en réjouis dans le temps du pluralisme
le pluralisme c'est plus riche ça permet
d'avancer davantage à une condition
c'est qu'on sache utiliser les
instruments qu'on a à sa disposition les
instruments une demirase les instruments
que nous avons à notre disposition c'est
la formation du gouvernement en tenant
compte des personnalités et des courants
qui s'expriment et deuxièmement par
exemple c'est le référendum
sur
l'immigration on aurait très bien pu
avoir un référendum sur ce texte en cas
d'échec la semaine prochaine est-ce
qu'il faut mettre ce référendum à
l'ordre du jour ah oui mais vous pouvez
pas le mettre parce que pour l'instant
la Constitution s'y oppose parce que
s'agissant d'un texte qui touche aux
liberté fondamentale vous ne pouvez pas
le mettre au
référend il faudrait changer il faut oui
sur l'économie oui économique et sociale
dit le texte il faut faudrait le
président de la République avait à
l'idée de mettre économique sociale et
sociétale
et peut-être on peut élargir le champ du
référendum qu'on appelle de l'article
11 c'est-à-dire qui une simple
proposition du gouvernement soumise au
français après un débat rapide à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat tout
j'avais même envisagé ce que je
comprends dans ce que vous nous
expliquez c'est que revoir le
gouvernement est effectivement quelque
chose qu'il faut envisager non je n'ai
pas dit qu'il faille envisager j'ai dit
explicitement le contraire c'est le
président de la République qui est
choisi et je me suis borné à constater
que bon c'est c'est c'est dans sa main
après j'arrête avec le c'est une arme
après j'arrête avec le chement
gouvernement pour prendre un nouveau
départ bien sûr que c'est une arme et
vous croyez que le Président de la
République ne le sait pas qu'Élisabeth
borne ne le sait pas que les postulants
nombreux presque innombrables ne le
savent
pas
ement vous nous avz confé dans J vousz
aé prier ministre mais que vous étiez je
cétait à cause de votre procès à
l'époque pour les emplois d'assistants
européens si vous êtes relaxé en en
février prochain je vais d'ailleurs vous
demander votre opinion sur sur ce qui
pourrait vous attendre est-ce que vous
seriez alors de nouveau disponible pour
matigon je je parle une seconde de ce
procès h euh j'avais pris la décision de
ne plus m'exprimer dans les médias
jusqu'au 5 février date du verdict et
puis l'accélration politique nous a
voilà la la fin du procès et puis votre
votre
charme l'actualité politique surtout
ou bon et l'actualité et la gravité de
l'actualité pour être sérieux m'ont
convaincu qu'il fallait que je que que
je passe outre cette décision que
j'avais prise donc je parlerai pas du
procès évidemment et pour matigon je
peux vous dire une chose du procès euh
c'est que je crois que nous avons pu
nous
expliquer pour la première fois en 7 ans
et donc vous êtes suffisamment expliqué
pour parler aujourd'hui en 7 ans euh
librement je crois que nous avons pu
nous expliquer on verra ce que la
justice en pense et pour rappel 30 mois
de prison avec surc 70000 € d'amende et
3 ans d'inéligibilité avec surc requis
c'est pas tout à fait le verdict monieur
pour rappel les réquisitions du parcour
pour être complet s'agissant de matinon
est-ce que donc une fois que cette ét
sera passé vous êtes vous n'êtes plus
hors jeu ces réquisitions
oui c'est violent c'est un
choc et donc voilà je
sais que nous avons pu établir un
faisceau de d'éléments de réalité et de
preuve et je crois
que dans ces 6 semaines
là une c idée de la justice pour moi a
éit rétablie après on verra alors on a
parlé de plusieurs scénarios possibles
on a évoqué à l'instant un changement de
de gouvernement il y a un autre une
autre arme dont dispose le le président
de la République c'est la la dissolution
est-ce qu'elle vous semble inéluctable
dans le quinquena au vu de la situation
politique que vous avez décrit pas du
tout je sais bien que là encore il y a
des gens qui en rêvent et encore mon
intuition c'est qu'il y a moins de gens
qui en rêvent que des gens qui disent
qui qui disent qu'ils en rêvent h parce
que chacun voit auss par exemple Jordane
bardé là pour le rassemblement national
qui l'appelle de ses vœux oui
euh c'est très simple sur les extrêmes
ma position est est
simplissime jamais dans l'histoire dans
les siècles passés jamais le pouvoir
donné à des extrêmes n'a fait le bonheur
et la vigueur des peuples jamais pour et
pour relancer le quinquena quelles
doivent être les deux priorités
d'Emmanuel Macron après la loi
immigration on a un grand souci de
finances
publies et je j'ai passé là encore
beaucoup d'années d'élections majeures à
me battre sur ce sujet on a un grand
souci de finances publiques et le le
levier
majeur
sur le rééquilibrage des finances
publiques c'est la capacité de la France
à reconquérir la production toutes les
productions la production agricole la
production industrielle la production
intellectuelle et la deuxème priorité et
et je crois qu'on a fait des pas dans
cette direction insuffisant et qu'il
faut bâtir alors là c'est le commissaire
au Plan qui une seconde
s'exprime il faut bâtir une stratégie
nationale produit par produit filière
par filière en voyant là où nous avons
des déficits euh
euh insupportable il y a des déficits où
on peut pas faire autrement hein le
pétrole on n' pas de pétrole chez nous
donc oui nous aurons nous avons des
déficits en énergie mais le nucléaire
permet de
compenser ses déficits en énergie
Emmanuel Macron avait avait défini lui
une une priorité alors c'était avant ce
qui s'est passé cette semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale mais il avait
défini une priorité pour le mois de
janvier c'était l'unité du
pays en en voulant parler à la nation
au mois de janvier ça peut être quoi ces
initiatives pour pour faire l'unité de
la nation parce que c'est un peu concept
quand même oui c'est c'est abstrait et
pourtant c'est l'impératif premier mais
la traduction politique deette volonté
ça peut être quoi
et vous voyez dans le monde les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement vousz vouslez
défiler dans votre esprit euh des grands
pays du monde et des pays moyens dans le
monde
il y a deux sortes de chefs d'État et de
gouvernement il y a ceux qui font leur
popularité sur l'affrontement interne du
pays les
populistes j'aime pas employer ce mot
parce que je trouve que le mot de peuple
est tellement beau que c'est ridicule
d'en faire une version péjorative votre
catégorie
voilà je crois à la démocratie et la
démocratie c'est la reconnaissance de la
conscience des peuples donc de ce point
de vuelà je n'aime pas par exemple Trump
en est un exemple je n'aime pas il y en
a eu d'autres he compris chez nous je
n'aime pas les gens qui cherchent leur
carburant électoral mais al en
versant de l' sur conrètement faire
l'unité du pays ça veut dire quoi faire
l'unité du pays à mon sens ça veut dire
reconnaître sa diversité ce qui veut
dire que la question du mode de scrutin
et de la reconnaissance du pluralisme du
pays la proportionnelle des différentes
opinions je dis même pas la
proportionnelle je dis une loi
électorale juste qui garantit que quand
il y a des électeur il a despou mais
vous pensez à la proportionnelle é légis
pour l'année prochaine est-ce qu'il faut
mettre à l'ordre du jour cette
proportionnelle l'année prochaine je
suis persuadé que pour qu'elle soit
immédiatement applicable pour les
élections législatives à venir je suis
persuadé que ça doit se faire et que ça
se fera référendum j'avais ça peut se
faire par référendum et je
soutiendrai serait pas la première fois
que je soutiens l'idée d'un référendum
sur le mode de scrutin qui
consacrerait cette
nécessité que chaque Français soit à sa
place dans sa démocratie que quand il
vote son bulletin de vote compte autre
priorité des parce que quand vous avez
un vote de gauche à ne qu'est-ce qui
vaut rien un
vote de de du centre à Saint-Denis
qu'est-ce qui vaut rien et un vote du
centre assez souvent partout ur il n'a
pas le poids qu'il devrait avoir et donc
la certitude pour que la nation s'unisse
c'est qu'elle soit reconnue dans ces
différentes composantes dans ces
différentes sensibilités et bien ça fait
une symphonie plutôt que d'avoir autre
priorité autre priorité des Français
l'éducation le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gabriel Atal a annoncé
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme à
l'école parmi ces mesures récentes
est-ce que c'est une piste qui vous
semble intéressante oui expérimentons
j'ai dans mes dans mes rêves nombreux
vous savez que j'ai plus de rêves que de
réalité parfois ça arrive à beaucoup de
gens dans mes rêves il y a que je
fondais une école parce que j'ai été
comme vous savez longtemps ministre de
l'Éducation j'ai adoré ça j'ai adoré ça
et donc euh je pense que ça a des
avantages et des vertus euh est-ce qu'on
peut l'imposer d'un seul coup je crois
qu'il est mieux d'expérimenter donc je
je j'approuve cetteel regard Gabriel
Attal ministre de l'éducation nationale
je pense qu'il a de bonnes
intuitions et que maintenant il faut les
faire entrer dans la réalité et il sait
lui-même que c'est pas si facile vous
lui dites que le plus dur reste à faire
là de la question d'uniforme évidemment
la question la rémunération des
professeurs de la condition matérielle
des élèves dans les classes bien sûr
vous dites le plus dur reste à faire sur
ce chantier là les oui de loin mais vous
voyez les orientations il y a il y a il
y a un très grand courant de ministre de
éducation il y a deux grandes
sensibilités mettons Chevenement et moi
et puis je crois que gabrielal s'inscrit
dans ce courant là
et et puis d'autres courants qui qui
allaient pas du tout dans ce
sens-l et je je suis très je trouve
que que de ce point de vue là il a il a
marqué des directions et des orientation
que je trouve juste ça fait 7 mois que
la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie a rendu ses conclusions depuis nous
attendons les arbitrages d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que vous comprenez ces
hésitations euh
oui si quelqu'un s'approche de ce
sujet sans avoir souci de
conscience alors ce quelqu'un-là ne
mérite pas la confiance qu'on doit lui
faire mais alors que répondez-vous à des
malades qui par exemple sont en attente
de cette loi notamment par exemple la
chanteuse Françoise hardardi qui appelle
le président à faire de l'euthanasie une
possibilité elle est atteinte d'un
cancer et souhaite partir le plus tôt et
le plus vite possible àelle 10 je pense
qu'il y a deux nécessité la première
c'est enfin de créer en France le réseau
de soins piatif que nous avons
été coupable de ne pas mettre en place
je pense que dans les services de soins
palliatifs c'est le sommet de humanité
qui se fait sentir
c'est la main qui se tend quand il n'y a
pas d'autre main et sur le suicide
assister quel est votre alors le suici
assister c'est encore autre chose c'est
donc le premier volet pour moi le plus
urgent et le plus important c'est les
soins palliatifs il y a encore
50 % des départements qui n'ont pas
l'organisation de soins palliatifs vous
vous rendez compte en
2023 et dans les soins palliatif oui on
aide mais sur l'autre volet on aide à
franchir sur l'autre volet pas si loin
que ça Olivier Bos parce que évidemment
quand on dit soin palliatif et le soin
palliatif ultime c'est la sédation
profond des continu c'està-dire jusqu'au
bout ben là c'est une manière de vous
aider à passer le cap est-ce qu'il y a
des cas limites oui il y a des cas
limites j'en
connais des cas qui qui pour pour des
raisons multiples disent
mais moi je veux qu'on m'aide à faire ça
il y a un législateur il va examiner
ça je j'ai j'ai beaucoup apprécié est-ce
que vous redoutez 10 mois de débat parce
que ça serait le Leonetti d'abord etcl
Leonetti ensuite parce qu'il y avait à
la fois le regard du médecin h et
l'humanité
du du frère et pour l'instant c'est pas
la direction que ça prend si on vous
comprend bien non pas du tout je pense
que je pense que euh on peut avoir sur
ce sujet des débats approfondis mais
vous avez senti que
je je ne veux pas qu'on oublie ceux qui
sont là au lit euh du
patient à l'ultime minute alors en
attendant qu'Emmanuel Macron tranche sur
ce sujet et rende ses arbitrages euh
votre camp se dirige vers les élections
européennes et se prépare ce sera le 9
juin euh dans quelques mois donc tous
les camps certains ont déjà désigné leur
chef de file ce n'est pas votre cas euh
est-ce que vous demandez urgemment une
entrée en campagne et avec la
désignation d'un chef de fil pour se
lancer est-ce que vous trouvez vous que
les Français euh vont nous attendre à la
sortie du studio en disant monsieur
Baayou non mais on sait que on a besoin
c'est la prochaine échéance qui
importante quand même et on sait que
l'Europe est l'une de vos priorités AV à
mon avis ben c'est pas l'une de nos
priorités c'est la condition de toutes
les priorités alors est-ce qu'il faut se
lancer
donc je pense que les Français vont
passer les fêtes sans soucis excessifs
sans se demander qu'il va conduire la
liste et en janvier ce que je j'attends
et voudrais c'est un c'est un chef de
fil qui soit puissamment animé de
l'inspiration européenne qui croit à
quelque chose que ça soit pas de la
politique que ce soit donc St journe ça
convient que ce soit le destin de la
nation ouais parce que c'est ça qu'on va
avoir apportter euh quel problème
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière question
en forme de réponse c'est surtout les
très les derni secondes quel problème
aujourd'hui la France peut-elle
affronter s'il n'y a pas une
Europe présente et puissante on vient de
voir Madame mélonie c'est s fait lire s
faitir en Italie en disant on va se
passer de l'Europe elle a pas pu elle a
fait appel à l'Europe merci François
Baayou